[Music]
[Applause]
Greg mroy ESPN ABC college football
analyst and former quarterback he won a
national championship and you ask him
about it he'd be happy to tell you how
he led Alabama to that National
Championship all by yourself didn't you
Greg yes it was a oneman effort uh
because football often is Dan as you
know you were like cam when cam was at
Auburn yeah just like him absolutely
could not be more comparable even in
skill set very similar okay uh is there
a downside to the portal transfer
portal there is um I I think that
there's probably more benefit to the
teams than there is to the player um we
celebrate the individual players that
wind up in better situations we
celebrate those that leverage I mean the
portal now in a lot of ways is used in
the way that uh holdouts are used in the
NFL to better your nil situation so guys
will go in not expecting to leave get
reup and then go back to school um so
it's used as a leverage mechanism but I
don't think there's enough attention
paid to the amount of guys that go in
that actually never come out they they
go in and they don't have a home so
we're seeing somewhere in the vicinity
of 20 to 25% of the college football
players overall entering the portal on a
yearly basis and very few of them are
ending up in better situations than the
one they departed and ultimately they're
end up having to walk on to places
taking on student debt and and that's
not ideal so that that's the underbelly
and the and the part that no one wants
to talk about but there is some good in
there as well why is Dion losing
recruits uh well a couple of days ago
about a week ago or so uh he came out
and said that that you'll make money
here in the nil world if you come here
and and prove it but but we're not going
to be the type of school that's going to
frontload the nil packages and I think
there was a was a response of that and
people are kind of connecting the dots I
think it's more about the way they
finished and some of the staff turnover
that they've experienced they just lost
their offensive coordinator well he was
their offensive coordinator he was
demoted mid-season and now he's the head
coach at San Diego State um that's Shawn
Lewis so that I think might have played
a role as well but I mean they lost six
to the last seven and and didn't look
great in the process so I I think some
of it's momentum based and some of it
might have to do with what Dion said is
related to nil and some of it might have
to do with staff continuity okay but how
sustainable is this for Deion Sanders he
was the Sports Illustrated Sportsman of
the year just named him that sustainable
of what he's doing in Colorado in your
opinion uh I think
it I think it's sustainable in a sense
that he's still going to be a hot topic
of
conversation um I think it's sustainable
in the new conference that he's moving
into that's the big 12 next year uh he
obviously is is well known around the
country but he's he's really well known
and really well respected in the state
of Texas where uh that's kind of the
heart of the Big 12 the new Big 12 um so
I think that that could be beneficial
and and we have to also keep in mind now
I'm I'm not gonna say that they had a
great year uh they overachieved on their
Vegas win total by a half game um and
they needed to pretty remarkable upsets
to be able to even pull that off that
one against TCU when they had the the
surprise element on their side in week
one when no one knew what what they were
going to do offensively or defensively
so TCU really didn't know what they were
doing they were kind of preparing for
ghosts uh but I still think progress was
made this year way more significant uh
as far as their competitiveness in in
year number one than they were in the
year before so I think it's sustainable
in the sense that they're going to
continue to be a problem for team teams
but are they going to take on the
college football world and just show you
the new frontier I don't know if I
necessarily am going to go down that
rabbit hole at the moment all right tell
me why Jim Harbaugh should leave
Michigan and why he should
stay well there's a million reasons why
he should stay there's also a million
reasons why he should leave uh should
leave and will leave are very different
things um I think that you go to the NFL
I mean we fire coaches in the NFL after
10 games uh owner doesn't like you
you're
out we found that out all too often with
what's gone on in Carolina the last
couple years um but there's a million
examples of guys that have gotten less
than two years right now he could stay
at Michigan for as long as he wants and
I think they got a real chance to win
the national championship this year and
they match up pretty well against every
team that might make the college
football playoff I think they look like
they're in a pretty good spot to to
handle their business this weekend and
maybe even uh become the number one
overall seed depending on what happens
with Georgia and Alabama in the SEC
Championship so I think there's more
reasons to stay than there are to go but
Jim har was a competitive guy uh almost
to a point where it might even be
considered a character flaw but I I
don't necessarily see it that way but he
lost to his brother and had it at the
five yard line going in and I would
imagine that's something that eats at
him probably every day so the
opportunity to get back and and kind of
write the wrongs of what went down this
last time in San Francisco I I wouldn't
be shocked if he took one and but I
think he's gonna take the right one I
mean he's been there's been rumors every
year that he's going to go it's been
Indianapolis it's been Minnesota it's
been Vegas it's been Denver I mean I
thought he might take all four um and he
hasn't yet so if the right one presents
itself with the quality quarterback in a
good situation with draft picks I could
see him definitely taking one Greg mroy
he was the quarterback of Alabama when
they won the national title in 2010 he
works for the mothership he has the
always college football podcast on uh
ESPN Florida state is without its best
player if you're the committee let's say
Florida State wins beats
Louisville do they pass the eye test
without having their best quarterback
because that you want the four best
teams in the playoffs would Florida
State be one of the four best teams in
America well Dan it's it's a real it's I
know what the committee tells us right
but they have not saying what you what
you expect it to be and actually doing
it are two very different things uh they
have not put in the four best teams
multiple times now we haven't had drama
in our sport since 2018 that was the
last time we had drama on selection day
so it's been a while it's been pretty
cut and dry chalky four teams that are
really qualified with an outlier that
might be able to make their way in um so
it's been pretty easy to digest since
2018 the last time though in 2018 Ohio
state was left out uh they were lost by
29 Points uh at two Perdue that year
they were 12- one Big 10 conference
title uh Champions they were left out in
favor of Oklahoma who lost by three
earlier in the season to Texas and
avenge that loss so it was pretty
understandable that Oklahoma be in over
allio state but that was really the last
controversial decision but if it was
really the four best and and here's
where I have a problem with it Dan I
know you look you you are are like me
like you love sports and and you want to
see the best and most competitive
environments
um I do too and I'm you know I don't
want to see blowouts in the semi-final
games of the national championship
that's bad for the sport but if we're
really going to go with the four best
then why don't we just let the NFL
Scouts tell us who the four bests are
why don't we let Vegas give us their
power ratings and here's the four best
and we just play a 15-way round robin
because these teams have the most Pros
if you're going four best then you're
probably going to go some some
combination of B Georgia Ohio State
Michigan Texas those teams have the most
Pros but that that's not what it should
be about I mean we in our sport more
than any others uh the regular season
has to matter I mean it's our strongest
attribute is our regular season our
postseason has been a mess for forever
and people have I think been turned off
by the sport because of the postseason
structure whether it was when they voted
for championships or it was just two and
now it's four and they think good teams
could still make it I mean the NFL
regular season is Elite because of
fantasy and all these other amazing
things that we follow but the NFC South
is going to get a team in the playoff
should they absolutely not that's not
one of the eight best teams 10 15 16
best teams in the league no well no way
no and host a playoff and host a playoff
and host and host a playoff game against
the team in the wild card that's
probably better than them so the NFL
postseason structure is amazing and it's
easy to to justify it's easy to
comprehend and consume ours is very
difficult that's why we're going to the
12 team which would be good but Flor
State should get in they did what was
asked of them they scheduled a difficult
team out of conference that would be LSU
they won that game by 21 points and
while they lost their quarterback a team
is more than one individual player I
mean would any anybody have picked the
Patriots to win the Super Bowl against
the greatest show on Turf with Tom Brady
I mean you never know what your backup
quarterback might do when given the
opportunity so there have been a bunch
of examples of backup quarterbacks even
the NFL that have gone on and have great
careers Tony Romo Brady a million others
that have been thrust into the spotlight
and end up being better than their
predecessor so I don't know if Tate
rodmaker is going to be that for Florida
State probably not but who am I to judge
what that team should be able to do
moving forward they should make it in in
my opinion give me the surprise this
weekend oh I I think Bam's I think Bam's
gonna be Georgia I I really do I think
they match up really well and Georgia is
excellent they're really good and they
have an elite quarterback and Dan you'll
be talking about this guy for a long
time Carson Beck's gonna make a lot of
money at the next level I think he is at
worst third fourth best Prospect coming
out and it's only because he just
doesn't have that much tape but I think
he's right there alongside Drake May and
Caleb Williams I think he's that good um
so he's unbelievable they have great
weapons on the perimeter Brock Bowers at
tight end lad Maki who's their number
one receiver but he's been a little
banged up this year they've had a few
guys banged up offensively but the
problem with Georgia is their defense is
just not what it was I mean when you
think Georgia you're thinking oh my gosh
like the last two years they are
unbelievable on the defensive side
they've been gashed for 200 multiple
times on ground this year Auburn did it
Bama has Elite Speed and good and good
offensive line a quarterback that can
really hurt you Georgia's 112 from the
country on yards given up on Zone reads
which is nuts to me a Georgia defense
giving up six yards per carry on Zone
Reed that's nuts so I think bam actually
matches up really well and Georgia now
is riding a 29 game win streak and and I
think it might come to an end on
Saturday afternoon you played for Nick
sabbin what kind of pep talk do you
think he'll have coming up this
weekend well when I was
playing you know you we've been doing
the show together for well I've been on
your a guest with you guys for 14 years
I would have probably gotten something
along the lines of don't screw it up uh
that would have been the that would have
been the message to me at at quarterback
so there's no raah there there's no you
know fire and brimstone win one for the
Gipper well I'd love to tell you that
there was he's kind of the same guy
every why I think the team is so steady
he doesn't ramp it up for for specific
games I mean what you what you get when
you're playing Chattanooga is the same
as what you'll get from Arkansas is the
same as what you'll get in the pregame
leading up to Georgia um everyone else
like he doesn't need to energize his
team like he knows how to press the
buttons if anything he wants to kind of
bring them down a little bit because
they're probably G to be on edge the
biggest game they've had all year it's
probably gonna be a little ramped up
maybe a little emotional uh he's
probably going to bring them down to
earth just a little bit this week and
and kind of hey Cal we're going to be
fine just execute the plan do your job
that's been the message kind of leading
into the game so you would expect him
tossing tables and you know like uh like
like Lou and in Major League where he's
flipping tables and stuff that's not
really how he is he's not banging
lockers he's if anything he's trying to
meet you in the middle because you're
already gon to be ramped up so he's I
think he's the best at at what he does
and being able to kind of keep things
consistent and that's why his team has
performed so beautifully in games like
this he's t won in SEC Championship
games in his career 10 and one which is
really insane I just can't imagine your
coach as you're getting ready to go out
play for a national championship hey uh
hey mroy don't screw it up all right
let's go get it yeah that pretty much
yeah
yeah hey I'll be honest with you if I
were in his shoes I would have probably
said the same thing great to talk to you
screw up thanks for joining us buddy all
right that's Greg Moy works for the
mothership he part of Georgia Georgia
Tech broadcast he'll be calling the uh
Big 12 title game Oklahoma State in
Texas that'll be uh noon Eastern